the ship is totally repaired we can
finally leave this [ __ ] planet
so long earth suckers enjoy the melting
ice caps
no no no no no no no no no no no
ah damn it hey we're still trapped on
earth this puts us right back to where
we were a year ago oh my god make a
bigger deal about it
i'm just glad everything is back to
normal yo dork
are you crazy where are your masks i
didn't know we needed masks i've been
breathing here for over a year
let's get the hell out of here quick
grab a scooter
[Music]
what the [ __ ] is that it's called big
dick energy and when i get it i'll be
unstoppable
i don't know a big dick seems really
dangerous run
everyone run i can't control this
distress calls we have to help them
looks like the solar opposites are going
to london what could go wrong
suck my butt officer [ __ ]
the solar opposites are going to jail
it doesn't have a hole we'll just have
to make one
okay how are we still so bad at this i
don't want to put
fingers at the weak link here but get
your [ __ ] together pew
this is gonna be awesome we're in the
big city you can be anything you want
out here
superhero politician orthodontist a
prostitute
you wanna have some fun sugar no [ __ ]
release your unholy creation are these
from brooklyn
[Music]
we're turning people into wines these
people love wine look how happy they are
on the labels